for you you made the white notice we
were at war
we're being slaughtered our sacred trees
cut down we need to defend ourselves
from her from you what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another game
of Thrones at A Song of Ice and Fire
Theory video today I want to talk about
several different characters but this
theory mostly revolves around blood
Raven and the children of the forest
some of the things I will say aren't
exactly original however I feel like I
have some new things to add to this idea
by the time I get to the end of the
video most of you will think I have lost
my damn mind and maybe I have but today
I want to take you deep into the murky
waters out into the abyss that is
covered in the thickest of tin foil
before I get started I do want to
preface this by saying I'm still not
100% sure this is true but I feel like
there is more than enough evidence to
make a good case when it comes to blood
raven and the children of the forest
they may not be as innocent as they say
their intentions and motives may be
driven by a much darker force
I think blood Raven is responsible for
bran Starks injury at the broken tower
Jamie may have been the one to push
brand but it was blood Raven who
influenced Brian to climb the tower at
that exact moment Bloodraven could not
allow bran to go to King's Landing and
become a knight like he wanted to he
needed bran to lose the use of his legs
that way he would need to find another
purpose in his life which ultimately led
to bran meeting Jojen Reed
Jojen was blood Ravens puppet and he
made sure Brian went beyond the wall to
meet Bloodraven Jojen was used just like
bran was used and as soon as Jochen got
brand to the cave blood Raven and the
children of the forest allowed Jojen to
die because he was no longer any use to
them not only did they allow Jojen to
die but they may have even fed Jojen to
bran to enhance his powers there is a
lot to unravel here in order for all of
this to make some sense so I will need
to start at the very beginning and
work my way up the blood Ravens death
there are some questions I think we need
to be asking ourselves what if we find
out blood were even and the chosen or
the forest were working what the night
King what if they were only using brand
because they needed him to help get the
night king south of the wall maybe the
children of the forest and bloodraven
were lying this whole time now I know
this may sound crazy because we seem
that children of the forest and
Bloodraven died in the cave while trying
to help bran and Mira escape but what if
that was a setup what if the children of
the forest we saw in the cave were stunt
doubles and those bodies were being ward
by the real puppet masters at the gods
eye which is where the most powerful
children of the forest are located what
the heart and the weirwood net now if
you're thinking about turning off this
video because it sounds too ridiculous
just hear me out like I said this might
not be true this might not be the case
at all
but I have been thinking about this for
a few days and there are too many things
that have happened that I'm still
questioning when it comes to the
children of the forest and blood Ravens
intentions and motives let's go back to
the very beginning when brain stark was
pushed out of the broken towers window
by Jaime Lannister now you could say
bran just happen to be at the wrong
place at the wrong time or you could say
this was brands destiny but another
thing you could say his blood were even
manipulated the events to make sure this
happened to Brian I happen to think it
was blood Raven and I will tell you why
green seers have the ability to see into
the future and they also have the
ability to speak through animals blood
Raven has this ability because he's
getting his powers from the same source
there is a great quote from the world of
Ice and Fire book that sums this up
perfectly in the ancient history section
it says legend further holds that the
green seers could also delve into the
past and see far into the future not
just into the future but far into the
future
ceptin Barth put forth that the children
of the forest could speak with Ravens
and could make them repeat their words
they could basically turn a raven into a
parrot this is something that blood
Bravin does throughout the entire book
series pretty much any time you hear a
raven speaking in the books you can bet
your ass that's Bloodraven speaking for
the bird
foreshadowing some of the big events to
come now as we all know Brian loved to
climb all over the castle he can move
around like a monkey and he climbed the
broken Tower often it was actually one
of his favorite things to do what he
really loved to do was climb the broken
Tower specifically because at the top of
this tower there were crows and Brian
liked to feed them corn right out of the
palm of his hand in Brian's second
chapter it says there were crows nests
topped the broken tower where no one
ever went but him and sometimes he
filled his pockets with corn before he
climbed up there in the crows ate it
right out of his hand
and it basically says the crows never
attacked him we're trying to pick out
his eyes that was actually blood Raven
and he wanted brain to be comfortable to
encourage him to continue to do this the
last thing he wanted to do was scare
bran away this was all part of his plan
he was grooming brand and he didn't even
know it
shortly after this is when brain is
pushed from the tower it actually
happens in this same chapter as Berean
falls and hits the ground george RR
martin ends the chapter by writing
something very interesting
this is what it says screaming bran went
backward out the window into the empty
air there was nothing to grab onto the
courtyard rushed up the meet him
somewhere off in the distance a wolf was
howling crows circled the broken tower
waiting for corn those last two
sentences foreshadow two very important
things
brains dire wolf was howling because
this is to show their connection or bond
with each other but why would George end
this pivotal moment by saying the crows
were circling above waiting for their
corn bran was just pushed from a tower
by the Queen's brother and for all we
know bran might be dead but the last
sentence of this chapter has nothing to
do with what just happened
the writer is reminding us about the
crows being there because they are
responsible for this incident Bloodraven
manipulated bran into climbing the tower
at that exact moment to feed the crows
corn and as soon as he got up there
bloodraven made sure bran was caught
because he knew what would happen next
Jaime or Cersei didn't just happen to
see brain in the window something
happened that caused them to look up and
see him there someone or something made
a noise that caused them to look but it
wasn't brain who made the noise it was
one of those damn crows Bloodraven had
them make a noise that way bran was
caught this is what it actually says his
brain is watching through the window
brain saw her face her eyes closed that
her mouth was open
moaning her golden hair swung from side
to side as her head moved back and forth
but still he recognized the Queen he
must have made a noise because suddenly
her eyes were open and she was staring
right at him then she screamed bran
doesn't remember making a noise in the
moment he thinks to himself I must have
made a noise because she suddenly looked
right at me
he doesn't say I made a noise he just
assumes that he did however I do not
believe it was Bryan who made the noise
I believe it was blood Raven let me show
you another quote that proves blood
Raven was using those crows after bran
is pushed from the tower he's in a coma
for many weeks and when he's in this
coma bloodraven visits him in a dream
sequence and this is what happens the
voice was high and thin Bryan looked
around to see where it was coming from a
crow was fire rolling down with him just
out of reach following him as he fell
help me he said I'm trying the crow
replied say got any corn that very last
line proves it was Bloodraven say got
any corn that's exactly what the crows
like to eat at the top of the broken
Tower
now the first phase of blood Ravens plan
is complete he found bran and he made
sure he never grew up to become a knight
because he needs him north of the wall
and bran never would have went if he
still had the use of his legs
now that bran is crippled Bloodraven his
initiating phase - now he's literally
inside brain's head encouraging him to
follow his orders the next thing blood
Raven does is send Jojen Reed green
dreams he needs Jojen to deliver bran to
him after all Jojen Reed was the perfect
man for the job
does Brian know the reeds are loyal
bannermen to the storks but bran was
also kinda looking for a friend because
he hated the fact that some of the
phrase were being fostered at Winterfell
Jojen was nearly the same age and he
helped brand find a new purpose in life
he helped bran forget about using those
legs don't worry because one day you
will fly all you have to do is follow me
you want to escape this reality of being
a [ __ ] I can help you this is exactly
what bran was looking for now that he
can no longer walk or run or even ride
horses the way that he used to things
are all going according to blood Ravens
plan the crazy thing is
Jojen knew he would be dead by the time
he completed his mission
Jojen could also see bits of the future
because of the Green dreams he was being
sent by blood Raven and or the children
he knew he would die and he even knew
Winterfell would be seized the sea is
coming here bran said Jojen saw it in
the green dream ale belly is going to
drowned maester Luwin tugged at his
chain collar the reed boy believes he
sees the future in his dreams sir
Roderick I've spoken a brain about the
uncertainty of such prophecies but if
truth be told there is trouble along the
stony shore
Jojen was right this particular green
dream was accurate even though Jojen
knew his own fate he went along anyway
and who do you think was making sure of
this
who the hell on the right mind would go
to this cave if you knew you were going
to die when you got there I know I
wouldn't unless someone was forcing me
in some way we never get to find out
everything Jojen knew because as soon as
he delivered bran to the cave
Jochem was no longer needed so he was
killed
there was no reason Jojen had to die the
way that he did Bloodraven knew exactly
what was going to happen outside of that
cave and he let it happen anyway think
about what he says when he meets bran
for the first time my brother he let us
see you and now he knew what would
happen
from the moment he left he knew and he
went anyway how do you know I've been
watching you all of you all of your
lives with a thousand eyes and lung he
says I've been watching you all of you
all of your lives with a thousand eyes
and one he can see everything not only
that but he has Ravens or crows
everywhere and he's looking through all
of their eyes you know Bloodraven was
watching them during their entire
journey there he knew they were
approaching the cave the children should
have been out there waiting for them to
make sure they got inside safely but
when do the children decide to help
not until Jojen is stabbed multiple
times
they set there and watched and didn't
help until bran was actually in trouble
they let Jojen die and in the books it
is theorized that they actually fed
Jojen to brand look up the theory called
Jojen paste if you want to learn more
think about how twisted that is Jochem
was Brian's friend and they made him
drink this weird paste that was most
likely jochen's blood and only the old
gods know what else was in there all you
have to do is look at the floor of the
cave to know the children of the forest
and bloodraven have been up through some
creepy [ __ ] for a very long time there
are bones and skulls everywhere and
those aren't bones from any of the
whites either the whites have never made
it that far inside of the cave they
explode right at the entrance and blood
Ravens layer is much farther back than
that now that he has bran inside of his
cave he can initiate his final phase
which I would like to call operation
invasion of the body snatchers brain
stark may have just been another pawn in
bloodraven or the children of the forest
game of chess there is a very
interesting quote by Melisandre that has
always made me question blood Ravens
true intentions when Melisandre was
looking into the flames she was thinking
about beyond the wall and how the enemy
was growing stronger and should he win
the dawn will never come again she
wondered if it had been his face that
she had seen staring out at her from the
flames
no surely not his visits would be more
frightening than that cold and black and
too terrible for any man to gaze upon
and live the wooded man she had glimpsed
though and the boy with the wolf's face
they were his servants surely his
champions Melisandre was looking into
the flames and wondered if she had seen
the great other the White Walkers are
their leader
she knew it wasn't their face but she
saw the wooden man which is Bloodraven
because he stuck in the tree and she saw
him with brian stark Melisandre is
thinking they are working for the others
they are his servants his champions this
is a fascinating piece of information
now we know the Melisandre has been
wrong before however I don't think that
means we should disregard everything she
sees I don't think it's that crazy to
think bloodraven may be a servant of the
night king we know bloodraven works with
the children or the forest and we know
the children were the ones who created
the night king in the first place maybe
they've been lying to us this whole time
they say they're trying to stop the
night king but how do we know they
actually are how do we know for a fact
that Bloodraven didn't use bran to help
get the night king south of the wall do
you remember what old naen told brain at
the very beginning of the story don't
listen to it crows at all liars
she told bran do not listen to crows
they are all liars we have no idea what
blood Raven may have been doing when he
was inside of the weirwood net for all
of those years another thing that I
found interesting is when Brandon goes
into the weirwood net by himself before
bran grabs the tree he looks at blood
raven and he notices his eyes are closed
Brian even throw something at him and he
doesn't move
Brian probably assumed he was sleeping
but maybe he was inside of the weirwood
net when bran decides he's going to take
a look for himself he doesn't grab one
of the branches that's right next to him
instead brian crawls over to blood
Ravens tree and he grabs one of his
branches and somehow the night king just
happened to be there waiting for him in
my opinion this
like a setup it was way too convenient
after the night King touches bran he
comes out of the vision in a panic and
somehow Bloodraven already knows the
night king touched him bran wasn't even
sure for himself but Bloodraven knew for
a fact now how did he know unless he
already saw this event happened or he
was inside of the weirwood net watching
it happen as it unfolded blood ravens
eyes were closed when bran through the
piece of bone at him but maybe he was
already in division watching from afar
or he set this up to happen if he is the
great other servant like Melisandre says
then this was all staged to happen to
bran we know there is still going to be
one big twist at the end of the series
the show winner said there would be
three and two already happened the final
big twist may reveal exactly what the
hell's been going on between the chosen
of the forest and the night king
sadly bran may suffer the most because
of this you also have to wonder if blood
Raven did actually hijack brans body it
appeared as if he was stuck in the tree
and I know if I was him I would want to
get out of that prison by any means
necessary
there are a handful of quotes that make
me think this is very possible
first when bran meets bloodraven for the
first time he asks him if he will help
him walk again but he tells bran know
you will never walk again but one day
you will fly now obviously this can mean
many different things some people think
it means he will fly through time while
others think it means he will warg a
dragon or it could just mean he will fly
by warding birds but what if he meant
that as bran would become him a newer
version of the three-eyed Raven he later
tells a brand that the time has come the
time for you to become me I'm sorry I
didn't mean to the time has come the
type of Woollett
for you to become me I know we have all
noticed how brain has changed ever since
his final night in the cave basically
right at the same time Bloodraven
allegedly dies we see the night King
swing his ice sword and Bloodraven
basically disintegrates but what if he
entered brains mind while brain was
still inside of the weirwood net later
after the rescued by benjin Mira says
the three-eyed Raven is dead but benjin
said he lives again from here on out
bran shows almost no emotions when they
get back to Winterfell Mira tells bran
she's leaving and going home but brian
has no interest in talking at all mirror
reminds bran that her brother died for
him
Hodor died for him but still bran shows
zero emotion this prompts Mara to say
Brian died in that cave prime I'm not
really aunt anymore
I remember what it felt like to be
Brandon stuck but I remember so much
else now
you died in that cave but what does that
really mean what if the writers are
hinting at something much darker than we
think bran even says that he's really
not brain anymore obviously brain has
been through a lot and he now knows a
lot because he's pretty much downloaded
the entire history of this world but
there may be several layers to these
scenes some a blood Ravens conscious
maybe inside a brand why did he help us
three-eyed Raven sent for me Fred Ravens
dead now he lives again and I also
wonder if blood Raven was actually being
used by the children of the forest as
well when we see the night King get
created the children had him tied up to
the weirwood tree in order to shove the
dragon glass in his chest when I look at
blood Raven all entangled into tree I
can't help but get a similar vibe I'm
wondering if the children of the forest
actually imprisoned bloodraven in that
cave and stuck him inside of the
weirwood root somehow I mean in the
books the weirwood tree is literally
growing through his eye socket basically
locking him in place we know that chosen
of the forest have no problem with
killing they created the night king so
he could wipe out the human race now
they say they were doing it to protect
their lands and trees but how do we know
for a fact that they were telling the
truth the children of the forest are
damn near extinct from what I can tell
there are barely any signs that they
even exist except for the faces they
carved into the trees men have taken
over everything don't you think they
would want some kind of payback
could they be planning something big
that we don't even see coming
we always hear the phrase all men must
die what if that originated from the
children of the forest from the time
they were at war with the first man now
we know the others eventually went rogue
and the children had to team up with the
first man in order to stop the others
from taking over and that's when they
signed the pact somehow the fighting
stopped and the others went back north
and the wall was built but the children
have also been living beyond the wall in
the same location as the
others more or less what if the children
of the forest and the knight King became
allies again both of them became races
on the verge of extinction while all the
men got to live south of the wall and
take over all of the lands the children
of the forest and however many White
Walkers that were still alive were
forced to live on the other side of the
wall I wouldn't be surprised if they
decided to go back to their original
plan of wiping them all out if the
children and men fought the others
together how the hell did the children
end up on the wrong side of the wall
don't you think this would piss them off
we know the men helped the children push
them back into the lands of always
winter but maybe as punishment they
forced the children to live with their
creation the others but over time the
children and the others planned to
strike back and take back their lands
for good which ultimately led to them
using bloodraven and bloodraven using
Jojen to get the brand and so on and so
forth it was all a part of their plan to
get the wall to come down so they can
invade Westeros and take back what they
feel was rightfully theirs now you might
be asking yourselves how are they allies
when we saw one of the White Walkers
kill one of the children in the cave and
Leif blew herself up so brain and Meera
could escape maybe they chose another
forest who are truly pulling the strings
have to be at the gods eye that's where
the main hub of weirwood trees is
located that's where this ancient pact
was made now I'm not saying the night
king is going there but the one true
puppet master is most likely there the
leader of the children of the forest
should be there amongst the sacred trees
they may have even recruited Howland
Reed since many people already believe
that's where he's at and that could have
also influenced Jojen Reed to help
escort bran to the cave the children we
saw died at the cave or sacrificial
lambs they died in order to gain branch
trust and our trust as a viewer but the
big twist will come in the end when we
realized the children reignited their
alliance with their creation the White
Walkers men have ruled for long enough
the true threat lies in the south
with one of the original races of this
planet it would also be really sad if in
the end John had to kill his brother
brand because his mind and body was
inhabited by these creatures who were
assisting the others when all this time
we actually thought they were trying to
help bran I will say that there is a
good chance that I'm wrong at the
beginning of the video I said I'm still
not 100% sold on this idea but some
things just don't add up to me I don't
understand why the chosen of the forest
would be living on the other side of the
wall where the White Walkers are when
they supposedly help man defeat them why
would they then be banished to those
terrible and dangerous lands unless they
were punished for creating them in the
first place and if they were punished
for doing this something has caused the
children and the others to become very
active again let me know what you think
about all of this down below I know
there is a lot to digest because I still
haven't put all the pieces together
myself because this is some complicated
stuff but I just said to get some of
these thoughts out of my head
anyways I want to thank all of you for
watching the video I really appreciate
you for coming along for the ride
hopefully it wasn't too bumpy for you
before I go I also want to thank
everyone on patreon for supporting the
channel that truly means a lot to me
have a great day everyone I'll see you
in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
Oh